أنا بروس كامبل وسأعلمك
كيف تصنع دمًا مزيفًا ، فأنت
تعتني بالشراب ،
فأنت تأخذ الوقت الواضح الذي تضعه على
الفطائر وليس الظلام ، حسنًا ، وليس
دبس السكر عيد الفصح ، امسح نصفه الفارغ
لزجاجة ممتلئة  من تلوين الطعام الأحمر ،
فأنت تأخذ قهوة ماتي
التي لا تحتوي على منتجات الألبان لأنك لا
تريدها أن تتحول إلى صفحة سيئة.
قطرات من
اللون الأزرق إذا لم تكن حتى زاهية
للغاية والوردي عليها كثيرًا من اللون الأزرق على الرغم من
أنها ستجعلها تختبرها السيدات الأرجواني أولاً
على سطح أبيض تكلفك
حوالي أربعة دولارات مذاق مثل الفضلات على الرغم من أن
الأذواق لا تزال مثل حماقة الشراب ساعد
لقد استبعد الأمر قليلاً ،
على الأقل كان رائعًا بصراحة ،
هذا كل ما تحتاجه هنا ،
إنه بهذه البساطة يمكنك صنع غالونات مخيفة
من تلك الأشياء